guns
masks you sure you all don't want to
grab some condoms
no why because this is usually what men
buy before they rape
someone oh we're not rapists us two
small fries no way it's gonna be cash or
credit for your rape kit
these guys uh forced jesse eisenberg's
character to rob a bank
and uh the bad guys and they're played
by uh daniel bryan nick schwarzenegger
for jesse eisenberg
i play his best friend and i help him
rob the bank
and michael's character chongo is
another guy who's kind of
involved in this whole world well the
only real scenes that i have with you
are when you smack me in the face we
have a little bit of a fight scene some
stunt work
plea i smacked him on the arm through
the head
and then there's something else it was a
really easy one but i did it myself
yeah i also did jason statham stunts in
the expendables
but that's a different issue you want to
be a millionaire travis
you got to start thinking like one we
forced some idiot
to rob a bank for us you know i played
the sidekick to danny mcbride so
danny mcbride's character has the scheme
to like i want to open up a tanning
salon
brothel you know every guy's dream what
a broken record that is
in this country um but he needs money to
get it going and so
you know i'm kind of like the
demolitions expert so he talks me into
building a bond that we can put on a guy
to make him rob a bank
and so i'm also have kind of a moral
dilemma with it and trying to figure out
like
you know should we do this and i kind of
go back and forth with it throughout the
uh throughout the movie
i was a really bad actor on set because
i was the one not only would i laugh at
other people's stuff when they were
doing it i would laugh at my own stuff
i'm like
and you're not supposed to do that no
it's not frowned upon we shot the film
in grand rapids michigan
grand rapids is pretty low key but you
know when we're there filming you're
there pretty much all day and then
you know you have a 12-hour day and you
go to bed and then you kind of wake up
and shoot again you don't really go to
the club
and the grand rapids club's probably not
really popping on a tuesday
it was i golfed a lot
i gotta i gotta admit it was pretty
interesting going in because i had a
mustache goatee shaved head with tattoos
and sometimes you couldn't wash them off
and i'm golfing they're like hi there
how you doing man
you golfing man i was like yeah man and
then i'm not that bad
and uh when they were like yeah i
continue up with that guy and i'm on the
t
waiting they're like no you can you can
let him go
i kind of have to you know kill the bad
guy
uh at the end of the movie and you know
using the flamethrower so
you know it was kind i had to use it i
didn't really i pretty much did that
stunt myself which was pretty horrifying
yeah he had a real flamethrower shooting
like 30 foot flames out of the front of
it it was intense i wanted like two foot
flames like i was like oh it's like
a big barbecue lighter reuben's like no
you gotta keep
doing it and it just was like after a
while it just wasn't so big
and it's like really hot i know it
sounds like stupid to say but
flamethrowers are really hot usually
like when you go in for buddy comedies
they'll like pair you up before
your cast like i went into like meetings
and auditions where they'll like you
know they'll pair you up and to see like
if you guys gel
so they didn't really do this at all so
they just kind of threw us together and
danny and i
you know we travel in the same circles
but we had never even met i thought it
was like a really fresh pairing just
because you know you think about
same with aziz and jesse i thought you
know there's certain different camps of
uh
comedy i guess you could call it you
know there's like the jedi apatow world
adam sandler world the will ferrell
world there's like these different
and they all kind of intermix and the
irons
yeah the jeremy irons world but i
thought this was really fun just because
like you know you've never seen
aziz's energy opposite someone like
jessie and danny and nick while they're
both so hilarious we'd never seen that
pairing before
i thought it was pretty cool to like
take kenny powers
from eastbound and down and then terry
the gay roller skating prostitute
and then just put them together in like
some super sandwich
homophobia and gay i like going to
movies and not knowing what's going to
happen
like when i first first saw back in the
future i didn't know what it was going
to be about and i was like what they're
like traveling in time in this movie
they're going back
it was amazing kid's hanging out with
his dad they're the same age splatoon i
had no idea what that movie was about no
i loved it demolition man wesley snipes
frozen
what don't watch trailers you should
stop watching the interview this is
going cold